frédéric il ya bien d'autres monuments
là qu'ils ont subis même genre de drames
que celui de notre dame de paris
mais parlons de cathédrales justement
céline celle de récents 1914 réduite en
cendre par un incendie causé par des
bombardements successifs par les
allemands un énorme chantier s'en est
suivie presque 20 ans et regardons
lagarde est justement une des
gargouilles de l'époque
est ce que vous voyez ici c'est l'espèce
damas de ferraille et de plomb qui
s'écoulait pouvons montrer vraiment à
quel point l'incendié étaient virulents
donc on l'a reconstruite on a changé les
armatures on a mis du béton armé et
finalement depuis 1938 elle trône
évidemment superbement dans la ville de
reims
autre cas cette fois ci c'est le palais
de westminster c'est le parlement qui
était complètement détruit en 1824 par
un terrible feu on l'a donc reconstruit
sa a pris presque 35 ans pour le
reconstruire avec big band donc c'était
évidemment énorme comme chantier est
très coûteux il faut être patient dans
pour voir la reconstruction de ces sites
a quand même ça près oui exactement
la cathédrale de dresde a fait les frais
évidemment des bombardements des alliés
il n'en restait rien regardez c'est tous
à peu près ce qui se tenait debout
donc on l'a reconstruite mais ça a quand
même pris du temps il a fallu attendre
1994 seulement jusqu'à 2005 afin qu'on
retrouve finalement ce qui restait de
cette fameuse cathédrale
un autre exemple c'est à moscou ce qu'on
voit ici c'est la cathédrale du christ
sauveur qui était détruite par staline
en 1931 on la dynamite et et regardez il
a fallu attendre jusqu'en 1995 pendant
cinq ans qu'on reconstruise est vraiment
ce super bénéfices selon les plans
originaux et puis aussi toujours dans la
région parisienne mais là on parle ici
de la basilique saint denis il ya eu une
tornade énorme en 1848 et regardez on a
perdu la flèche et la tour et donc on a
gardé malgré tout les pierres on les a
numéroté pour pouvoir les reconstruire
et que ça ressemble à ceci on va
reconstruire à partir de 2020 et ça
pourrait prendre onze ans imaginez vous
parlez de patience mais reconstruire
c'est bien sauf quand est-ce qu'on peut
tout reconstruire au fond mais la
question se pose mon trois exemples avec
le palais impérial de berlin qui était
rasé en 1950 qu'est ce qu'on fait eh
bien on a décidé de reconstruire selon
les cas original mais seulement la
façade tout ce qui serait l'intérieur ce
sera moderne donc ça c'est un choix
deuxième cas
et palmyre qui était partiellement
détruite par le groupe armé état
islamique qu'est ce qu'on fait qu'est-ce
qu'on reconstruit des ruines où est-ce
qu'on retourne finalement dans le dans
le passé c'est complexe
et puis aussi les cas où on ne peut plus
rien faire en afghanistan les fameux
bouddhas géants de bamiyan
mais ils ont été dynamitée par les
talibans il n'existe plus rien donc là
c'est un cas de figure où c'est
impossible de reconstruire
quelle tristesse quand même merci